it's an honour for us to be back on
stage Francis do you have anything to
end nope nope nope nope thank you very
much
here are the nominees for performance by
an actress and a leading role jalisa
greets young Glenn Close the way Olivia
Colman the favorite Lady gaga
a star is born now listen to Carson can
you ever forgive me
and the Oscar goes to Olivia called
Megan this is the first Oscar and
nomination for the
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh it's genuinely quite stressful
asked me I have to thank lots of people
if by the way I forget anybody I'm gonna
find you later I'm gonna give you a
message snog and I'm really sorry if I
might forget now but your gosh my best
director in the best film and with Emily
and Rachel the two long videos woman in
the world to fall in love with him to go
to work with every day I mean you can
imagine it wasn't a hardship and to be
to be in this category with these
extraordinary women and Glenn Close ie
you've been my idol for so long and this
is not how I wanted it to be and I think
you're amazing and let me very much and
love you all Thank You Lyndee King my
agent who took me on over 20 years ago
thank you so much and olive and Hildy
and Brynner who made me do things I
thought I said no to but she was right
and my mama my dad will you know and
then my kids are home and watching look
well if you're not then we're kind of
well done but um
sort of hope you are this is not gonna
happen again
and and any little girl who was who's
practicing their speech on the telly you
never know and when I I used to work as
a cleaner and I loved that job I did
spend quite a lot of my time and metonym
it's all please wrap up right okay and
thank you and my husband ed my best
friend I love you so much
25 years Matt you've been my best
supporter he's gonna cry I'm not and
thank you so much like a fox
everybody everybody the cast the crew
Francis thank you oh thank you so much
Oh Lady gaga